- [Narrator] Plane tickets,
gasoline, groceries.
Inflation has hit the US hard.
In 2022, the consumer price index rose
at its fastest pace in
more than four decades.
- So the CPI, as it's more commonly known,
is pretty much the most
closely watched indicator
of inflation in the US,
and consequently, the world.
- [Narrator] The consumer
price index estimates
the change in prices for a basket of goods
and services that represents
the average household spending.
Calculations made from that basket
are used to make decisions
that affect Americans
all over the country.
Decisions about adjusting tax brackets
and benefits like Social
Security and food stamps.
And it's one of the indexes
watched by officials
at the Federal Reserve.
- Against the backdrop
of the rapidly evolving
economic environment,
our policy has been adapting
and it will continue to do so.
- [Narrator] But how
is this basket selected
and used to calculate the CPI?
And when shaping policy decisions,
why does the Fed pay the most attention
to a different index?
(playful music)
The department in charge of the index,
the Bureau of Labor Statistics, or BLS,
looks at several categories,
each given a different importance
to compute the month's percent change.
Some of the most important categories
are food, transportation and housing.
- When you pull that all together,
housing is a big, I mean,
it's the biggest expense that
we pay for out of pocket.
Rent, your mortgage, that's
gonna be a hefty chunk
more than anything else.
- [Narrator] The BLS gives
each category its relative importance
based on a survey of what consumers buy.
Keeping track of all of those
items people spend money on
and their prices changes month to month
is the job of BLS's price checkers.
The agency employs over 450 workers
who track prices for up to
100,000 goods and services
and 8,000 housing units every month
based on the survey of what
consumers are purchasing.
To make sure products
they are price tracking
haven't changed, they compare the product
to a list of data points
from the month before.
Sometimes that list can be up to 11 pages.
This process helps to
ensure the CPI's accuracy.
The BLS is basing those calculations
off of an urban consumer
paying out of pocket.
The formula excludes non-direct spending,
like payments from nonprofit organizations
that provide services to households,
Medicare and Medicaid,
and employer-sponsored healthcare plans.
But again, this is just an average.
(till beeping)
Inflation affects different
people differently.
- How you feel inflation depends a lot
on what's in your spending basket,
and how that differs
from the average person's
as captured in the CPI.
If you have to drive to work every day,
you are feeling inflation a lot more
than the person who has to take the Subway
because the gas prices
have gone up so much.
- [Narrator] And the index
doesn't include everything.
That's why some, like the Federal Reserve,
prefer indexes they see as broader,
like the Personal-Consumption Expenditures
Price Index, or PCE.
- Over the 12 months, in
April, total PCE prices,
that's Personal-Consumption
Expenditures Prices rose 6.3%.
- [Narrator] One of the reasons
the Fed prefers this index
is that the CPI only transitions items
in and out of the basket every two years,
while the PCE changes
its basket month to month
based on consumer trends.
The variations in how CPI
and PCE are calculated mean
that the two indexes
can reflect American
inflation slightly differently
but the Fed takes both into account.
- The Fed's monetary policy actions
are guided by our mandate to
promote maximum employment
and stable prices for the American people.
- [Narrator] Looking at
multiple indexes gives the Fed
a broad picture of American inflation.
- CPI's undoubtedly something
that they're watching closely,
especially the month-on-month movement,
like that's an important
gauge of it does this,
inflation we're seeing,
does it have momentum?
- [Narrator] And rising
inflation of vital items,
especially over long periods of time
can cause more issues,
like inflation becoming
embedded in the economy.
- We at the Fed understand the hardships
that high inflation is causing.
We're strongly committed to
bringing inflation back down,
and we're moving expeditiously to do so.
- [Narrator] When inflation
remains high for too long,
consumers begin to change their behavior
in ways that can keep prices elevated.
- So for instance, like oh,
my bills are getting really expensive,
so I'm gonna ask for a raise
and then your boss is like people seem
to be willing to pay my higher prices,
so I'll just give this person a raise
and raise my prices.
That keeps inflation
kind of chugging along
in a way that can be eventually
harmful for the economy.
- [Narrator] By looking at
changes to individual categories,
like housing and food,
consumers can learn specific information
from the overall CPI.
- That's gonna give you a
sense of whether inflation
is broadening, and that's
really the concern right now
for the economy.
- [Narrator] The CPI is a useful tool
for economists and consumers alike.
And it's a good indicator
of whether inflation
will begin to subside
or whether it will become
more embedded in the economy.
(dramatic music)
(items beeping)